Boy, is it hot. I can hardly stand it.
Where's Maestro?
Yeah, I am right here, right?
What a heat wave.
It certainly is.
Do you know what heat really is?
It's where the temperature goes up.
It's on the beach in the sun.
When I bring home a bad report card, it gets hot.
Heat is fire.
That's interesting.
And fire, well, what is that?
Well, it's when things burn.
Do you remember Democritus the Greek?
There are in nature four elements, earth, fire, air, and water.
This branch is from the earth, and it turns to fire when it burns.
No, Metris, there are not four elements.
There's one element, basically, just one, the atom.
Now, who can stand it? Such awful heat.
Would you bring me a glass of water?
Thank you. Now, 2,000 years later, in the 18th century,
scientists still thought there were four elements,
earth, fire, air, and finally water.
Here you are.
A new science. Chemistry was about to appear, and it would help us to understand what matter really is.
Who was the first chemist?
Many scientists could claim that, but above all, a Frenchman, Lavoisier.
Alas, he was guillotined.
They chopped his head off.
Oh, no. Don't laugh. It was a tragedy.
Anyway, Lavoisier.
Heat is a very special element, but it is an element.
We might more scientifically name it frugiston.
Yes, Monsieur Levoisier.
Do we know what phlogiston's made of?
Uh, no, not exactly.
But one day soon, we will surely find out.
Yes, but then why talk about it?
Phlogiston stopped floating, little lamb.
My good sir, I only thought I wanted to.
Good people of Paris should have better street lighting than this.
At the age of 23, Levoisier would receive a gold medal from King Louis XV
for his contribution to lighting the streets of Paris.
He'll be admitted to the Academy of Sciences, and in that same year, he became what they called a farmer general
Which later was to cost him his life. What's a farmer general well back then a farmer general was really a tax man
And why did it cost him his life? You'll find out look for sale the pure water of the sea
Gentlemen, it's a serious problem. There's not enough pure water for the city of Paris
The sense water is impure to install some pumps and bring in spring water that would do no good
In any case, the water would be transformed into earth.
How do you know that, monsieur?
It is well known.
Tell me, what is your name?
Antoine Lavoisier.
Monsieur Lavoisier, when water remains in a recipient, a residue of earth will form,
and the weight increases, since earth is heavier than water.
I doubt that.
When pure, it stays pure, unless something else has been added.
And so, young man, you would refute what is known in science?
Yes, and I will prove it.
Delete one more time to be sure that it's really pure find out a vapor does transform directly into earth
I know this pure earth now that a month's up. We'll see what we see
Well would that be earth man?
There is some as it evaporates water turns to earth
Well, then in in that case the flask should weigh more is that right?
Yes, because the earth is heavier. I'll wager. There's no change in weight now. Let's see
So it weighed two pounds three ounces to grow in 15 grains. Let's see the scale there
Now the weights: two pounds, three ounces, two grow, and fifteen grains.
There, you see?
We saw the earth. It was there.
We'll weigh the water, right?
It's not earth. Maybe it's only bits of the flask.
No! No!
In this case, water wasn't transformed into earth. They were changed into mud this time.
You haven't heard the list of this. You'll pay for this, amateur!
You see, in nature, nothing can be lost and nothing created. Only transformed.
No, you see what he meant. Nothing is destroyed, nothing is created, only transformed.
It's one of Lavoisier's great discoveries, the basis of our modern chemistry.
You see, my friend, fire is the great mystery that I want to comprehend.
Ah, these flames dancing on the wooden logs and giving off their gentle heat.
You don't want to what, my child?
So old, a boar, a dreadful boar.
But he is a cow daughter and a personal friend of the Minister of Finance. That could be useful.
Marianne, I haven't introduced you, Monsieur Levoisier, a colleague, a tax inspector, but a scientist as well.
Will you pardon me? I, uh, I was distracted.
Oh, no. Oh, I'm very sorry, oh.
Monsieur, the Count Damaval wishes to see you.
Yes, well, such a charming child. Quite delightful. I'm delighted. Quite delighted.
Willing to exceed your wishes, we shall marry since you insist.
You're insisting, sir, I'm not.
Look here, my daughter, come.
Forgive her, my dear Count.
It's nothing, it's charming.
Charming.
Overcome with emotion.
You will be a Countess.
Oh, I understand that you have come to ask my daughter's hand in marriage.
She is so young, Count.
Yeah, so young.
So pretty, so attractive.
So I have the honor to request the hand of your daughter in marriage.
Marianne, you hear my child? He asks for your hand. He'll marry you.
You'll be a countess. Surely your heart flutters with joy.
It does seem to me your daughter's heart is beating quite normally.
Who is this unexpurgated person?
Uh, him? No one, no one. He's, uh, Antoine Lavoisier, a farmer general and a scientist.
Farmer general, eh? My dear child, I don't think you realize a count is asking for your hand in marriage.
A count, and that counts. No, wait, do you have another suitor?
No? I shall challenge him to a duel instantly.
Monsieur Lavoisier, why are you giggling like a goose?
Sir, I have the honor of requesting your daughter's hand in marriage.
It's ridiculous. Why, you hardly know her.
I know I'm in love. I can tell by the beating of my heart.
Couldn't possibly hesitate between a clumsy tax man
and me, the Count of Amaral, of the illustrious ancestors,
and a personal friend of the Minister of Finance.
I won't hesitate one minute, except with joy with all my heart, Monsieur Lavoisier.
Mr. Priestley, it's with pleasure that I welcome you to the Academy of Sciences.
We're eagerly waiting to hear the results of your experiments.
And I, gentlemen, I'm eager to have your opinions.
Gentlemen, whenever we heat calcinate of mercury, we obtain a quite special gas.
Which we call oxygen.
And so in the air, there are two sorts of gases.
Very good, excellent word.
Ah, stuff of nonsense. Air is air, no more, no less.
And phlogiston transmits the heat.
- No, phlogiston doesn't exist.
There is an air that permits fire to burn,
another that won't.
Look here, you see?
The good air is used up.
The burning ceases.
- It's because the phlogiston's all gone.
- How?
The bell would have contained it.
Now look at what the good air will do.
- It's like that we've seen.
Don't tell me that phlogiston doesn't exist.
It's written right here.
- Hundreds of old ideas,
even if they're written down, are wrong.
Only experiments using the scientific method
create new knowledge.
- Oh, you talking nonsense.
Yes, the next few years were to be, for Lavoisier, full of intense activity.
Here's one of his agricultural experiments.
For a good wheat harvest, the best planting field is one where sheep have already grazed.
I fenced in the field with the sheep.
Now we'll let them graze upon it for about a year, and next year the harvest will double.
You'll see.
That's wasteful, surely.
No, it's not. Come, take a good look.
You see, my last year's experiment.
The growing wheat is twice as thick here, and believe me, the harvest this year will be excellent.
Wanted to see it up close like that.
I'm glad you're so interested.
I trust you agree.
You see, the wheat is considerably thinner here.
With a magnifying glass as big as a person,
we might succeed in separating the gases.
I'm pretty sure you're right, Mary.
Oh.
Majesty, you Monsieur Le Boisier?
Yes, I am.
France needs you.
Our enemies are about to attack and we're short of gunpowder.
We need a great deal for the cannons.
I'm ready to serve my country.
And I'm sure my wife wants to be with me.
Your potassium chlorate might replace the saltpeter that we're lacking.
I'm sure it will create an excellent powder for cannons.
Carry out a test, Mr. LaVosier, but watch out for explosions.
Saltpeter? What presumption?
You'd better get behind the barrier all the same, Mr. Money.
No, no danger. It won't explode no matter what.
You see, Mary Ann, there are really two sorts of air.
Vital air and another air that does not support life.
Look at this.
The vital air is just about all used up.
We see the mouse is slowing down.
Could be the runnings tired him out.
Wait. Hear that? There is air in there.
But he can't breathe it. Watch. See that?
Vital air didn't last terribly long.
I understand what's wrong.
I was right. This vital air, I'm going to call it oxygen.
It's oxygen that allows a fire to burn and a body to warm up.
I'm going to do another experiment with my friend Laplace.
Titian.
Yes. Wrapped in felt, the ice is protected from heat and won't melt.
We're going to put in an animal, and with his body heat, he'll melt the ice.
You won't put this poor animal in the ice.
Not at all. We'll put him in this small container, which he'll warm with his body heat.
Don't you think his body will freeze?
With oxygen, he'll stay warm.
You see, the ice is turned to water.
We can calculate the quantity of the creature's heat.
Sure, he's still alive.
Of course.
Today, we think that's all terribly simple.
Yes, but it was revolutionary. Revolutionary!
Well, I was here in Laplace had measured the heat given off by an animal.
They had calculated how much oxygen it had consumed.
They had also measured...
Eminent English chemist, Cavendish, confirms that water, gentlemen, is not an element.
What's that? Water, not an element, sir? And that, would you say that is?
That, monsieur, is a combination of hydrogen and oxygen.
If you'll permit, I'll prove my point. This way, gentlemen.
In this one, oxygen. In this one, hydrogen. This container here is empty.
Now look. You see, we've obtained a quantity of water absolutely pure, formed by the two gases.
Is anyone thirsty?
Such a concoction.
Bollicle!
Excellent. This water is absolutely true.
So, children, do you realize the extraordinary discovery by loved ones?
What is this?
Here in this glass, eh?
Liquid sunshine.
It's water.
Yes, it's water, but then it's also a combination of, uh, of...
Two gases!
Yes, which ones? Let's hear it.
There's hydrogen and...
Yes, and...
You should all know that.
I just told you!
Oh, dear, oh, dear, oh, dear.
Hydrogen, two parts. Oxygen, one part.
- Meh.
- Formula for water is H2O.
- We must reject old ideas
and base our science on experimentation.
It's the only way to progress.
There's no such thing as phylogiston.
Air is composed of at least three different gases.
Oxygen, which is vital air.
Nitrogen, a gas that can sustain
neither life nor combustion.
And hydrogen, a very light, highly flammable gas.
Balloon is filled with hydrogen.
It's much lighter than air.
It could lift a man right up.
- So, rubbish that.
Crazy talk, twaddle, baldadash, silliness.
I gather you don't agree, Monsieur Monet.
Then do test it, come right up.
Uh, go ahead, prove that you're right.
We'll both go, we'll teach him a lesson.
And he'll admit that he is talking nonsense?
Heh.
Just hold this rope, will you?
So just get--
Chemistry has to recognize there are basic elements in nature.
Iron, sulfur, carbon, oxygen.
Bravo, Monsieur Lavoisier, your theory is a veritable revolution.
The revolution's about to begin, the French Revolution.
And citizen Lavoisier is going to play an active part of it.
Formed at the revolution,
those concerning our system of weights and measures is urgent.
We all agree.
The system we have is too complicated.
Let's begin with weight.
We have the ounce and 12 ounces constitute a Roman pound.
But it's 16 ounces for a Paris pound.
And what about the Troy pound?
Not forgetting the grain.
And the grow.
There's also the scruple.
And the petit pois as well.
Listen to me now, citizens.
All measures have to be compatible in the same metric system.
Here, this is a cubic decimeter.
A cubic decimeter of water weighs one kilogram, that is equivalent to a thousand grams.
And that is our system of weights.
It certainly has to be the simplest, most logical system in the world.
Lavoisier was interested in everything.
He did so many things that I won't have time to tell you all of them.
And so, all systems of measurement are harmonized.
Citizen Lavoisier, they request your presence at the Finance Commission.
It's very important that the financial burden be borne by all,
the rich paying more than the poor do.
Monsieur Lavoisier, they want you at the assembly.
When a person grows old and is no longer able to work,
under no circumstances is he or she abandoned.
Because national solidarity must step in.
And will proceed next to the calculation.
Oxygen consumption during exertion.
In January 1793, Louis XVI will be guillotined.
And soon the revolution will run wild.
Citizens!
Suppress all decadent, learned societies, well!
Citizen Lavoisier is an enemy of the people.
He has foreign friends and was a farmer general.
Look here, citizen Mara. LeVarcier is a great scientist, and science is international.
He works for the good of the country.
You there, who are you, citizen?
Could it be that you too are an enemy of the people?
Warrior!
It's by using oxygen that the human organism obtains the energy it requires.
The first thing to discover is what fuel in the body actually burns this oxygen.
An experiment on this subject would...
This was the reign of terror.
guilty or just suspected or innocent hundreds of people were to be guillotined they have to be
killed no pity citizen fouquier lavoisier may yet give france a great deal more i request we
postpone his execution until he has completed the project he's working on besides the man's not
guilty he's a servant of the people the republic has no more need of chemists or of scientists
proceed with the execution my life has been long and happy enough i think people will regret my
passing and my reputation will live on.
Who can ask for more? Lavoisier.
Tom, gerbaud, ponzé.
Lavoisier, du pontel,
chevalier.
It's true. Why'd they do it?
Madness. Stupidity of humankind is infinite,
my children. Every day you see examples
of mindless cruelty, and you must
fight it with all your strength. Lavoisier,
a man of science, he knew that.
And he left us all, each of us.
A precious legacy.
Think of all that we didn't understand.
It's just 200 years ago.
All that he discovered for us.